speaking of people who are confused here's
something that's been making the rounds on
um on Reddit
this is posted by a an
account called males of Reddit
as a screenshot of someone on the the trans
Forum the male to female transform on Reddit
and here's what they posted they said
I have successfully breast fed my child
this is a male Again by the way my kiddo was born
last week and I was the first to breastfeed her
my partner and I gave her well they've well
they've they are recognizing the sex of their
daughter so that's something at least you gotta
look for the glimmers of Hope where you can
find them especially in a situation like this my
partner and I gave her 40 hours of continuous skin
to skin after she was born but after after months
of preparation and trying I was able to breastfeed
my own kiddo from my breast it's a wild feeling
it made me over the moon happy she's a cutie
and then there are screenshots of a bunch of
comments saying that uh you know how wonderful all
this is the religion of leftism is anti-religion
which means there isn't anyone to turn to when
things don't go their way there's no Transcendent
being pointing you toward truth and Beauty there
are no Customs or Traditions to keep you on
a righteous path and there's certainly no app
like hallow to help leftists reclaim their peace
Hollow is an audio guided prayer and meditation
app it's the number one Christian Prayer app
in the U.S hello it's like calm or headspace
but without the woke nonsense because it's rooted
in Christian faith with thousands of meditations
and prayers I use hollow to find peace after a
long day of being yelled at by blue haired zazam
weirdos they have over 5 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and Christian music as well you can
pray alongside Jim Caviezel Bishop bear and father
Mike Schmitz Markle Wahlberg and many more hello
helps me make prayer a priority and they can do
the same for you so get an exclusive three-month
trial at hallow.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh reclaim your piece in this crazy world
download hello today now it should go without
saying but I feel that I must say it anyway
um it is not possible for a man to breastfeed
a child okay that's not something that that
can actually be done you cannot sustain a a
child that way now what is possible and what
has apparently happened in this case is that if
you take if you're a man and you take a whole
bunch of hormones and you drug yourself up this
way that after a while you may start secreting
some there may be some secretions that come
out of your nipples which is disgusting but
that's that that may actually happen so these
are going to be hormone these are going to be
these secretions hormone laced with artificial
hormones that are now being ingested by the child
it could that possibly be remotely healthy for
a newborn child to be ingesting that whatever
that is okay and we're not going to call it's
not it's not it's not it's not it's not the
mother's milk it's certainly not that whatever
you want to call that mucus those secretions
uh is it healthy for a child to be ingesting it
is there any reason to think that it would be
obviously not but as always it's not about the
child this is certainly extremely physically
unhealthy for the child not to mention the
psychological damage being done even at such a
young age but that doesn't matter it's not about
uh it's not about the child it's about this guy
no this is a this is a a fetish for him this is
a desire that he has and that he has now forced
a newborn child to participate in well I hope you
enjoyed that clip from Matt Walsh show if you did
be sure to subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get more content
like this if you want to watch or listen to the
full show head to dailywire.com And subscribe
today you can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your podcasts